hey milkshakers welcome to metaphysical
milkshake i am rain wilson and i'm uh
reza haslam
and um
i uh
god you know
i'm sorry i know i've got this
script right here on this google doc
right in front of me to read from but
i'm i'm gonna
put that aside reza can i just i'm a
little distracted can i say something
sure what
reza sylvester aslan not my middle name
you're looking a little peaked today
yeah
i'm a little worried about you i mean
you know i was just like watching cnn
and
you know
ukraine you're watching the network that
fired you yeah that was best first of
all that's a
that's a problem but yeah normally
you're like a seven but today you're
like uh
you're like a hard six if that a 5.5
you're looking like you're looking a
little worse for wear what's going on i
gotta be honest with you man i'm a
little bit uh i'm a little bit upset at
just the world the state of everything
that's going on in this country and
you know the
land war in europe what the [ __ ] like
where are we
what year is this what decade is this
partisanship here the government's
broken people suck sometimes i gotta
tell you man i just feel like i feel
like stepping stepping off this world
going and being a monk or something like
go live in a monastery somewhere
just kind of you know meditate all day
long and do nothing else
yeah well you know what roz i got some
news for you that's not going to work
it's not going to cut it
well what do you mean like that sounds
like a great no no no no today's monks
today's monks are different today's
monks don't just sit up in their
monasteries
staring at their navels and watching the
sunrise
they are
actively participating in the community
of monks in building community
in their meditation and mindfulness
practice so that they can become
activist monks and bring that into the
world to help alleviate suffering on a
daily basis on a global scale
yeah that sounds like too much work i
just thought maybe i would eat tofu and
you know meditate and stuff
no you thought it was like going on a
cruise or something why don't you just
go on a cruise
huh that's actually all right that
sounds better i was thinking about
becoming a monk but maybe i'll just go
on a carnival cruise instead problem
solved carnival cruise for two weeks
there you go to the bahamas to bermuda
that problem solved look interviews how
we solve
inner boom boom
welcome to metaphysical milkshake the
show where we go deep we get weird and
we search for the meaning of life along
the way presented by cast media and soul
pancake
we do have a couple of monks today uh
this is exciting it's our first episode
with four participants by the way
so
that should be interesting we have uh
brother fapu and sister true dedication
both are monks from the plum village
monastery both are uh
acolytes of the recently departed uh
master tiknot han
uh the famous peace activist monk
and
they have some really uh exciting
resumes
sister hyen negim who or true dedication
is was the editor of several of tiknot
hans books and is a leading voice in a
new generation of young monastics she's
from the united kingdom previously
studied history and political thought at
cambridge worked as a journalist at bbc
and then was ordained at the age of 27
and became a dharma teacher in 2016.
and she helped to found the
international wake-up movement a
community of young meditators who are
finding new ways to combine mindfulness
and engage in buddhism she has a
wonderful ted talk from 2021 called
three questions to build resilience and
change the world we've also got brother
fapu who was born in vietnam then
emigrated to canada and he first
encountered tai or
han and the monastic community as a
nine-year-old
when he traveled from canada to plum
village france he knew he wanted to
become a monk by the age of 12 this guy
was destined to become a monk
and for 15 years accompanied tiknot han
as his personal assistant on his
international teaching tours and as his
attendant please welcome sister true
dedication and brother fapu
welcome to metaphysical milkshake
hi we are
here to be with you and we're very happy
about it
uh we couldn't be happier and uh ever
since i met you at that ted environment
uh climate conference
um
in uh in edinburgh i knew we had to have
you on the show and
um i got so much out of meeting you
about hearing your ted talks we did a
short little workshop i don't know if
you remember on forgiveness
that was really powerful and moving um
and uh
whatever you wisdom that you have
we could sure use over here
across the pond as they say so um we're
just
couldn't be more thrilled to have you
that's right yes we're really excited
about this conversation and you know
before we begin we just wanted to kind
of begin by
just you know giving you our condolences
about about the passing of tiknot han um
he's such an incredible and important
figure for so many people for those in
our audience who maybe are unfamiliar
with tiknot han
he is a spiritual leader a peace
advocate um
someone that martin luther king jr
actually nominated for a nobel peace
prize in in
1967 king actually said about tiknot han
his ideas for peace if applied would
build a monument to ecumenism to world
brotherhood and to humanity um we're
obviously very familiar uh with his work
and his legacy but
as as you know
two individuals who were very close to
him and his teachings and learned so
much from him how would you summarize
and describe his life his work his
legacy
i'll start um
he is the embodiment of peace
i first came to plum village in 1996 i
was very young only nine years old
i wouldn't say i understand the dharma
that much but
what i got from the first trip to france
in that retreat was
meeting someone
who is walking his talk
so the way he was walking the way he
looked at us the way he
um invited us for a cup of tea the way
he ate lunch with us it was really
the practice of mindfulness in action so
for me um you have described him as a
peace activist as
a spiritual leader
but for me what i would definitely say
is he is
a teacher that has a lot of
understanding and a lot of love
and he was able to translate the deepest
teaching of buddhism into everyday
language which is
how do you become happy just by brushing
your teeth
how are you
enjoying
the sunshine that you experienced today
he gave us these key
teachings to make our own life more
beautiful what i really appreciate about
him
was he was so down to earth and i think
this is something that not a lot of
people get to see um i had
the great honor of being his personal
attendant for over 15 years so
i would have tea with him um go on walks
with him and he was very encouraging and
he's always somebody who is
telling us that
you have the capacity
to be
an awakened person you are someone who
has all of these
qualities inside that are just waiting
to manifest and he
is the gardener that helps us
see these flowers see these plants as
well as see the weeds and see
that the branches that needs to be
cleaned up
so for me he was a living
teaching of mindfulness a living
teaching of non-violence of peace and of
love
that's beautiful
sister true dedication i would love to
hear your thoughts on this as well and
um
uh brother fapu talked about finding
happiness while brushing your teeth so
is what you're saying because the the
point of our conversation with you is
like how do we find peace in an insane
world this is the life's big question
that we would love to dig into with you
so
are you saying you don't need to be a
monk to find inner peace one can find
inner peace while brushing one's teeth
and living
slap dash in the modern world
so i think peace is made of moments of
peace right and then all of us have a
chance to create those moments of peace
wherever we are and here in the
monastery we're just trying to string a
lot of them together and we have a lot
of very supportive conditions but we're
just as human as you all
and
so we are also
actively creating the moments of peace i
think peace is not something that comes
from the outside necessarily
it's a response to a situation it's a
response to our interpersonal dynamics
at work or at home
it's our response to what we're seeing
on our screens
and watching in the world
so peace is maybe a way of being a way
of responding it's not something that
kind of comes at you from the outside
and for me when we talk about what our
teacher's great
impact has been what his influence has
been for me it's
it's like
it's hard to find the words but i would
just say
a kind of legendary man of peace like i
think it's very rare in one lifetime
that you can have a chance and for me i
just feel so lucky that in my lifetime
i've had a chance to like be alive at
the same time as this person to be able
to receive teachings from from him and
and that's just extraordinary and
so yeah i i think he's the
pretty cool
i don't know how to say that
wait but wait wait rather i just think
that was the quote of the day he's
pretty sister true dedication saying
that he's pretty cool yeah
i think
that's going to be his new like slogan
uh take nothing pretty cool pretty cool
guy
folks you know this most coffee is dull
still and frankly questionably sourced
but it's easy to get stuck in a rut and
drink what you always have so instead of
standing in front of all the options in
your grocery store let trade coffee help
you find something new to love trade
sells the freshest roasted and ethically
sourced beans from america's best
independent roasters and then they ship
it free to you as often as you like
whether you want it whole beans or
ground whether you're a coffee nerd or
just want a better daily cup trades real
coffee experts taste test over 400
roasts and use technology to match you
to your ideal coffee based on your
preferences and brewing method this is
how it works you take this coffee quiz
and then trade coffee guarantees that
you'll love the first bag that you get
or they'll replace it for free trade has
been featured by the new york times
wired gq and has delivered over 5
million bags of coffee their
subscription is no hassle you can skip
shipments change your frequency or you
can cancel at any time i mean rain you
took the the coffee quiz right i took
the coffee quiz yeah you know
i've been uh drinking a lot of decaf but
i took it with my wife and we got i
forget
what happened you choose the kind of the
flavors you like etc how you take your
coffee etc and it is fantastic it's a
subscription service to coffee how come
we didn't think of that we could have
been billionaires by now and for our
listeners right now trade coffee is
offering a total of twenty dollars off
your first three bags when you go to
drink trade dot com slash milkshake so
it's very easy to get started go to
drinktrade.com milkshake take the very
very fun coffee quiz and then you can
start your journey to the perfect cup of
coffee that's drinktrade.com
milkshake for 20 off your first three
bags
hey milkshakers is your company or
business having a tough time hiring the
people you need this is a crazy
workplace environment what do they call
it the great resignation the great
resignation
everybody is changing jobs everybody's
like leaving work
it's hard to afford the right people
it's hard to find the right people i
mean it's yeah it's kind of crazy but uh
it's hard to keep up on your hiring and
workable workable helps all types of
companies
with this issue there's 46
more jobs being posted than before the
pandemic that's crazy and they're 44
percent fewer candidates applying to
each one so you need to find the right
candidates and hire them fast and
workable can help workable accelerates
every step of your hiring process from
fined to higher workable helps you cast
the widest net possible by posting your
jobs to all the top job boards more than
200 of them by the way with one click it
helps you evaluate and hire quickly with
modern tools like video interviews and
e-signatures and workable will help you
automate repetitive tasks like
scheduling interviews so you can spend
your time on what's important which is
making hires
so whether you're hiring for your coffee
shop or your podcast or your engineering
team workable is exactly what you need
to hire the right people fast
start hiring today with a risk-free
15-day trial if you hire during the
trial which many do it won't cost you a
thing
just going to get applicable yep
workable.com to start hiring workable is
hiring made easy
you know we were talking about rain was
asking about you know does one need to
become a monk to find inner peace and i
think that's kind of one of the the
great message of
of tiknot han is that no i mean that's
like we're all responsible for that we
can all find it in our own worlds and
stuff but i do think that it's it's so
interesting because
people people have this strange
impression of monks i'm sure i don't
need to tell you that right like if you
just walk through an airport in your
robes i'm sure you get enough looks from
people because i think we
understand kind of how one becomes a
rabbi or how one becomes a priest or how
one becomes a pastor or whatever but
then
we don't really know like how do you how
does one become a monk like do you you
know do you sign up on craigslist uh you
know what
are you responsible for your own robe
okay you got a b-y-o-r bring your own
robe
you know i think they're available on on
amazon you can you can get them on
amazon i wouldn't be surprised if you
can find ropes on amazon nowadays
well the pandemic we're all basically
wearing robes now uh all day all day
long
uh you know do you shave your own head
do you have your friends shave your
heads do you shave each other's heads
inquiring minds want to know is what
we're trying to say here how do you
become a monk
how does that work so let's start um
first you have to have an aspiration
in order to become a monastic it's
it's not something that you
you wake up and you're like i want to be
a monk today um that wasn't my case
but um
we we speak about a spiritual dimension
um our teacher talks a lot about this he
says that
everyone needs a spiritual dimension in
their life and it and a spiritual
dimension doesn't mean you have to be
buddhist or
it doesn't even have to be a religion
because for us
being mindful of your breath
allowing your body and your mind to be
united that is a spiritual dimension
and we go on a quest to
to find a way to become a more
beautiful human being
and for me and all of us who are
monastic here
at some point it led us to plum village
it led us to a retreat in the plumbus
tradition and
we're gonna encounter this community the
teachings the way of life
and it might spark something deep down
in our deepest aspiration that tells us
that this is the path that we want to
embark in and we want to invest
110 of our energy into
and that's the first part and the way it
goes is then you write a letter to the
community you share about your
aspiration
and then the community has a program
called the aspen program it's like
internship so you get trained for one
year
so you have monk internships we have
monastic internship it's not as wow as
it sounds to get in but it's not okay
okay also
yeah but you live the life as a lay
person a lay person is like you reign
with hair and a beard and we don't
expect you to shave it
but you are already living the life of a
monastic for you to really see is this
my cup of tea
and for the community to observe you and
to also see
are you capable of being a monastic is
it is it just a honeymoon idea like
you're gonna be in la la land and like
meditating and levitating but actually
becoming a monastic it's just the first
step once you're a monastic there's a
lot of internal work you're gonna do
you're gonna recognize your own
suffering you're gonna recognize habits
that
are gonna be telling you what are you
doing in this monastery what are you
doing with your life
and so you get to
explore and experience this life already
as an aspirin as just a normal person we
do give you a particular robe it's not
brown it's gray so it tells you you are
training to become a monastic
and and one like a jedi it's like a jedi
yeah it's like a jedi but you don't get
the lightsaber yet
okay
so
and then when there is an ordination
date the community would meet so on the
monk side the monks would meet for the
men and on the woman's side the nuns
would meet for
um the aspirin woman and there are a few
criterias that we look at um number one
is are you open enough to be trained so
let's say reign and raza if you aspire
to become a monastic you're older than
me in age but if you become a monk
you're my younger brother
and so you would have to have the mind
of wanting to learn
you have to learn to let go of your
knowledge of the world in order to
be retrained in a way
another criteria is
can you live in harmony with us because
we're very community based we all share
rooms
we are a community of monks and nuns
with over
30 nationalities we come from different
backgrounds some of us grew up buddhists
some of us grew up as
catholics as christians some of us
didn't believe in anything so just so
many different backgrounds but suddenly
here we all are with a mind of wanting
to
have a higher awakening a liberation
from within
at the end of the day there is a deep
aspiration is for us to be more free
to be enlightened but the question is
always what are we wanting to be free
from what are we wanting to be
enlightened from
and for us that comes in different
stages
okay how's the food
you you
the first training is entering into the
kitchen
everybody needs to learn to cook rice
needs to learn to boil vegetable needs
to learn to um
fry tofu needs to learn to make a dish
for the community that's part of our
training we eat very well rain but we
eat a vegan diet so it's it's super you
know super healthy super good for the
body
yeah what do you think well i mean i
think i think uh i would like it uh if
for no other reason than uh just to have
you know a moment to myself i have way
too many kids as uh you may not know but
you can't use the monastery as a get
away from me i think it's a perfect
excuse it's the perfect
say to my family i believe i'm being
called to something much higher
and i will be gone at least a long
weekend at least a long weekend we'll
see did you know rezzy you can bring
your kids to plum village you're one of
the few monasteries that does retreats
for whole families
but then actually so you bring your kids
and then the monks and nuns take care of
the kids and then and then you you have
your retreat experience and then the
children are climbing trees and playing
literally writing this down right now
that's fantastic and there's more than
one plum village right there's one in
near san diego right there is it is in
escondido it's called deer park
monastery yeah but okay but i mean
i don't want to
i mean if it's like france or escondido
i think
that's pretty good to france yeah
which one i'm gonna go to
but uh but no i'll take that i'll take
that under consideration
okay sister true dedication i get a
question
tiknot han
said once the present moment is filled
with joy and happiness if you are
attentive
you will see it we've been talking about
this for a little bit of time people are
using his ideas of mindfulness
uh as a tool to achieve this
attentiveness
there's certainly a lot
of stuff out there about mindfulness but
let me just tell you something i set me
straight because i have a big problem
with the word mindfulness i have a big
issue with it
and that is this my mind
is my enemy
my mind is in a constant state
of you know the buddhist
monkey mind um it's comparing it's
contrasting it's envious it's judging
it's con it's it's ruminating it's it's
speculating it's bouncing around this is
what my mind is doing all the time so if
mindfulness to me sometimes feels like i
need more mind in my life when actually
i want less mind in my life don't you
think that we should call it being
fullness
what do you think
i think that would be great
feelingfulness being fullness okay
some people like to say heartfulness i
think the idea is that
when your mind like my mind when our
mind is taking us away in a thousand
directions
um our mind is not right here and right
now with our body with what we're
feeling and especially with like what's
going on around us so the idea is it's
like we we plug our mind back into our
body into our feelings and so we just
have a lot more
sensory awareness
of
how our body is how the coffee or tea is
that we're drinking how the people are
that are around us so in fact it's like
instead of our mind wandering in a
thousand directions it comes home
and it kind of opens up to what's
happening so i think that's maybe where
the mindfulness is because it's like
instead of mind craziness and mind um
going in a thousand directions it's mind
coming coming home
and
i think the trick is that i think you're
right about the mind part of it
sometimes we say that how do you know
you're in the present moment is that you
can feel it you can hear it you can
touch it like if you can hear the birds
you know you're in the present moment if
you can really taste the sweetness of
your cookie you know you're in the
present moment if you can smell the
fragrance of your coffee or tea you're
in the present moment so i think for me
mindfulness it it's it's much more of a
felt sensation and like you come to life
like you really you realize all these
sensory inputs that are going on and
that's where i begin when i want to step
back into the present moment when i
realize
my mind has taken me away somewhere else
i love the way that you're talking about
this
because of course mindfulness
you know i mean this is an ancient
spiritual practice not just you know in
buddhism but in so many religious
traditions it predates you know religion
insofar as this idea of
becoming one with
the the universe in the present moment
and and
you know everything that entails
but of course like most things we've
completely screwed it up
uh we've commodified it we've
commercialized it it reminds me a lot of
like what yoga has become in some ways
you know there are now all these
mindfulness apps and
and tools
i don't know if you're familiar with
this mindfulness app headspace
right it was invented by a buddhist monk
or a former buddhist monk uh
you know and it's now it's worth three
billion dollars so
this is literally a multi-billion dollar
industry
uh predicated on quote-unquote
mindfulness and so i wonder like there's
good and bad about it and the yoga is a
perfect analogy of this i mean i'm sure
a lot of practitioners will say well yes
of course a lot of the spirituality has
been stripped of yoga but it's still
good and people are still doing it and
who knows it can it can act as a kind of
doorway to a much more meaningful
spiritual
practice instead of like a way to lose
weight you know um
i wonder like do you
do you feel something similar with
mindfulness and the way that it has
become this kind of commodified
commercialized
you know thing which is it's still good
but it's it's got all this like baggage
now
how do you how do you reconcile that i
wonder
i think how we reconcile is that
we have to
be the real mindfulness that
people are seeking
and i think one of the
things that people
won't touch is the deep teachings of
buddhism because mindfulness is just
a tiny
speck of the whole teaching
and
the reason why
it has become what it is today is
because of the human greed and the human
mind of wanting to profit out of it
but
in
before we used to have um our teacher
used to tell us that there's always
popular buddhism and then deep buddhism
and now i can say there's popular
mindfulness and now there's going to be
deeper mindfulness and actually
mindfulness is just one of the eight
noble paths of the deep teaching of
buddhism
to be mindful is just one of it you have
to practice mindfulness in order to have
right view
that's a whole training in itself to be
more free in your views of life in your
views of good and bad
left and right up and down darkness and
light
and then we have um right speech
mindfulness is not just breathing
mindfulness is how are you speaking to
your loved ones how are you training
your teach um how are you training your
children how are you teaching them the
way of life but in a compassionate way
it's very easy to be angry but are you
mindful of the way you are expressing
yourself
and then mindful action
the way we live our life everything that
we do every day that is
a signature that we are leaving behind
um i think
you both are parents so
our teacher always says you know
as parents we're always giving to our
children just by the way of our life so
our action is also a contribution and so
we have to be mindful of the way we are
living our life and then we have right
livelihood we have a deep aspiration to
be peace to
to offer good to to life to protect our
planet but are we living in a way that
is speaking our deepest aspiration we
have to ask that
um there is right diligence are we
are we even practicing what we are
aspiring are we doing
what we're telling other people to do
there there needs to be a diligence and
for us that diligence comes to how are
we taking care of our mind our mental
formations
are we feeding our anger every day are
we feeding our despair every day or are
we
learning from our suffering are we truly
exploring to help
civilization
get out of the suffering that it is in
or or we continue to drown ourselves in
it and then there is mindfulness of
concentration and then mindfulness of
insight so there's just so
it's so broad and this is deep buddhism
and mindfulness is just one of the keys
the bridges into a spiritual dimension
the deeper teaching of mindfulness is
also mindfulness of suffering
we have to practice to become aware of
the suffering that is in us
around us
and also even go deeper see the
suffering that we have
is connected to even our ancestors
and then our civilization and if we make
a change today that's also a
transformation that we are doing for our
whole ancestral lineage so mindfulness
is
just one of the teachings and i think
if somebody does go through an app and
they figure out
a technique of mindful breathing and
that
kicks in a curiosity and they want to go
deeper
plum village we hope that we will be
that place that doesn't get lost and
doesn't um go in a direction that we try
to commercialize make money out of it
but it's more of like
we are a spiritual refuge and that is
what
inspired us to join this monastic order
uh inspire us to become students of zen
master technical and to be his
continuation
folks we all have our favorite go-to's
right shirts sweaters jeans the stuff
you wear all the time i mean there are
times when i will go like two three days
wearing the exact same black shirt
over and over and over again this
morning this is a true story this
morning i got up dressed and realized
that all my new go-to's are from the
same place buck mason
buck mason's clothes are second to none
they're timeless they never go out of
style everything i own fits great right
out of the box and instantly becomes my
new favorite item of clothing and this
is the best thing buck mason makes all
the essentials there's jeans shirts
jackets all my go-to's and so much more
i love the tailored look and fit of
their t-shirts like they actually make
me look skinnier than i than i really am
even after wearing them and putting them
through wash after wash they look just
as good as when i first wore them
especially the curved hem t that's my
new favorite gq loves it as much as i do
they call it the best t-shirt in the
game folks well here's the thing i'm
always looking for a t-shirt that
actually kind of fits my body
and um they make fantastic t-shirts it's
hard to find the right t-shirts you know
do you try the big brands they don't fit
your body the right way buck mason
t-shirts
a-okay in my book a-o-k aslan
and once you try buckmason they'll
become your go-to favorite t-shirt too
all you got to do is head over to
buckmason.commilkshake
and you can get a free t-shirt with your
first order that's b-u-c-k-m-a-s
milkshake and get your free t-shirt with
your first order
buckmason.com
milkshake
milkshakers let's get real i think we
can all probably up our fruit and veggie
game don't you think reza no don't you
think tell me about it man i need i need
more foods and more veggies in my diet
but listen
i'm just it's not gonna happen unless
it's easy in fact i made a new year's
resolution
that this year i am going to keep my
freezer stocked with daily harvest daily
harvest is the easiest way to get more
fruits and veggies into my day every day
they have my back with delicious food
that's good for me and good for the
planet i'm not kidding i have two
refrigerators in my house because i have
14 children and both of them are
jam-packed with daily harvest i got the
harvest bowls i got the flatbreads i got
the smoothies i got the desserts that
they've got
all built on organic fruits and veggies
they come right to my door and it stays
conveniently fresh in my freezer
what are your some of your favorite uh
daily harvest items reza well the
smoothies are out of control good i mean
they got like 14 different ingredients
in them they never uses preservatives
added sugar or artificial anything and
that goes for everything they have so
many delicious options for every time of
day breakfast lunch dinner dessert or
snack daily harvest has you covered
daily harvest is all about preserving
and protecting the earth for current and
future generations to come from the
recyclable and compostable packaging to
investing in organic farming practices
and reducing food waste you can feel
good about the choices you are making
physically for the environment daily
harvest makes it easy to feel good about
what i'm doing for myself and the planet
and you can feel the same way all you
got to do is go to
dailyharvest.commilkshake
and you can get up to 40 bucks off your
first box that's
dailyharvest.com
milkshake and you'll get 40 off your
first box dailyharvest.com
milkshake
[Music]
the thing that kind of most intrigues me
about
your master's work and your work
is
how you have to kind of go inside in
order to go out
your mindfulness practice unlike maybe
say some other
buddhist traditions and other monastic
traditions
doesn't uh advocate for disengagement
with the world
but you talk about
compassionate action and i love that
phrase as i was kind of studying about
um your master's work and your work
compassionate action nearly 50 years ago
gary snyder wrote the mercy of the west
has been social revolution the mercy of
the east has been individual insight
into the basic self
and void
and we need both
so you are
self-described activist monks i met you
at a conference on climate change and
we'll get to that in a minute but um
master tiknot han
talked uh about
you being activist monks is it necessary
to tend one's inner garden including
this practice of mindfulness and you
talked about the mindfulness of
suffering as being kind of the next
level
in order to then go out and give service
so what is that relationship between the
mindfulness work the buddhist work and
practice that you do
and how does that connect to the moral
imperative that includes compassionate
action
so i think any activists and all the
activists we meet i think the biggest
danger is burnout right and even many of
us who maybe not even don't even
identify as activists but it's very easy
to burn out in
in life right now i think
so many things are changing so fast and
so much destabilization is going on
and
so the energy of mindfulness for us we
call mindfulness and energy so that also
sets us apart a little bit from maybe
other folks who call it a tool or a
method for us it's an energy that we
generate every day with our way of
breathing our way of walking our way of
listening and our way of being with one
another
that's i just want to pause for a second
if you forgive me i'm not gonna
interrupt interrupt but that is that's
that's exceptionally revolutionary i've
never heard that before or thought of
that before mindfulness not as a
practice or a tool but as an energy
so it it's an energy it it fills your
batteries are you you you're able to
draw a deep on a deeper kind of
cosmic or divine energy from
from practicing it
yeah so say like you wake up in the
morning and you're feeling rotten
you roll out of bed and you know you're
sitting on the edge of the bed your feet
are on the floor
if you take three full in-breaths and
out breaths and you're just like this is
my life this is my day i'm still alive
in those like three breaths we would say
you've generated a little bit of
mindfulness you've generated a great
energy that will then hold you when you
walk to the bathroom right
and then the bathroom this is where the
teeth brushing comes in
you look at the mirror
and you smile and you're like i am still
alive that is me
right
and then you brush your teeth with some
awareness how fantastic i still have
teeth to brush isn't it great this is
the only part of my skeleton i can see
you know you have a great moment
in front of the mirror brushing your
teeth right
you're generating an energy that's like
embracing your life experience that day
and then when you turn around to the
person you live with and they're having
a bad morning
you have naturally this energy of
presence and compassion to be able to
embrace them because you've kind of
arrived into your morning in a certain
way
so it's exactly that it's like a little
battery and every time you have a moment
these little islands of mindfulness in
certain actions where you're really
there feeling it living it deeply being
in your body being with the physical
movement the sounds the smells the
tastes
you're just kind of like plugged in and
plugged into life and then that brings a
different quality
so that's the the energy of mindfulness
it is a kind of superpower and all of us
can have a little bit of it and we we
generate it whenever we can throughout
the day
and so as an activist
this is the energy that is holding us
this is the energy that's like kind of
cushioning us as we go through the
sequences of difficult and sometimes
critical moments that happen in our
activism and in our engagement in the
world
this is a struggle that i have and this
is a
legitimate and sincere struggle that i
have with western culture especially in
the kind of more liberal secular cities
um
so much of people's quest for anything
spiritual is simply because they feel
anxious
disconnected
um and directionless
and they're looking for some inner peace
and some inner solace and it ends there
and it stops there and this becomes very
solipsistic
where a yoga practice or a meditation
practice is simply
to reduce anxiety
and it isn't seen as a battery
that charges as a force
um as then listening to the bombs in the
moment so that you go help the people in
the bombed out villages
how can you what would you say to people
in contemporary america around this this
issue of kind of almost a selfish use
of the mindfulness practice
simply to just kind of make their lives
a little bit more tolerable i'm sorry
that i'm a little bit
i have a little bit of bitterness and
anger around this because i i i find it
incredibly frustrating
maybe we wouldn't call that mindfulness
i think we would call that like kind of
panacea like we'd call it it's it's it's
something
you're not trying to wake up
you're you're actually helping yourself
be a bit more comfortable a bit more
asleep
and just to get through the day and keep
it all going as is
so i think we wouldn't recognize that as
actually
what we call mindfulness which is a kind
of spiritual energy that helps you wake
up to see your life more clearly and to
see what's going on around you more
clearly
and then when you see things clearly the
ethical action the motivation the
intention the change is automatically
triggered and put in place because
as as brother farpoul was saying you see
the suffering you want to bring relief
you see the suffering of your colleagues
your family members you want to help
like there's this sort of dynamism in
real mindfulness which
is an awakening to suffering which leads
to a deep wish to
change and for action and movement and
if we're using mindfulness as a kind of
something to consume a kind of comfort
food
then
i mean yeah i wouldn't really call it
awakening i wouldn't call it the kind of
mindfulness that we recognize as that
energy that really helps open your eyes
and open your heart
in in all truthfulness thank you so much
for saying that that's so beautifully
and perfectly said and that really helps
my heart to hear it and uh really thank
you for that answer as a matter of fact
it
really gets to the heart of why we
wanted to speak with you guys because
i think you know most people when you
um
talk to them about monasticism you know
what they think of is
withdrawal and isolation and rejection
of the world you know uh it's a purely
internal exercise you know i think
that's the general impression
that a lot of people have about oh
you're a monk when you just like
sit cross-legged and think about stuff
you know all day long and what's what's
amazing about what you guys do
is that that internal work has is a
means to an end the the end is the
external right that it begins inside but
it doesn't end there that it's about
taking it out into the world
um sister i think you once said
something along the lines of we need to
act with the urgency of today and the
patience of a thousand years like that's
a great
line that kind of perfectly encapsulate
this belief system that it's
you recognize the way that tiknot han
did
you know that we are facing a world that
is on fire right now we've got we've got
a a global pandemic where we have a
ground war in europe i mean
uh you know enormous economic uh
upheavals uh
widening gap between the the poor and
the rich
repressive state-sponsored violence
death death of democracies around the
world
here in the united states the kind of
unhealable partisan divide racism
you know uh
sexism
and don't get me started by the way we
also have an ecological collapse around
the corner so all of that
is
with the the fact that the planet is
slowly dying and so
you know i've thought about that talked
to wait about this i've talked about
this on the show that sometimes when
faced with these kinds of issues and
conflicts i think to myself
it's too much i think you know maybe
i'll just go be a monk maybe i'll just
go and ignore the world and just you
know go internal and just be inside and
what i love about what you're saying is
that's the opposite of what it means to
be a monk that it's it's about engaging
precisely with the world but from a
place
of inner peace and inner understanding
and i just think
you know if there's any kind of advice
that you could give
to
our listeners people like us who
you know maybe we don't have the ability
to to do what you have done but but are
inspired to kind of focus on the inside
so that we can then put our gaze outside
um
you know what what can you tell us what
can you tell us you know for those of us
who are
really on the verge of just kind of
giving up
and saying you know what forget it all
it's uh it's all on fire and i'm i'm
just not gonna
think about it anymore
i think don't underestimate um the mind
of love that is one
number two is to
have this insight
that our teacher have made up this new
word that he's still trying to put into
the dictionary he kept keeps talking
about it
and it's this insight of deep buddhism
that everything is interconnected
and the language the word that he came
up with is inter-being
this is because that is
everything
is so connected to each other and if we
have this insight we can remove more and
more discrimination we can remove more
and more separation
of
the differences that we see the idea of
happiness the idea of suffering and i
think
the more that we can be free from
particular views that we have what is
happiness
we can find a new way and i think this
particular moment this crisis that you
just explained
it is very overwhelming
but
it is also humans that made it but it is
also humans that can wake up and can be
a spark of hope and a spark of change
and transformation is possible because
everything is of the nature of
impermanence
what is today can change tomorrow and
that depends on everyone's action of
body speech and mind
and
the insight of inter being also tells me
that you don't have to do this alone
that there are
those
that are around the globe
that has the same aspiration and one of
our
teachers biggest aspiration is to have
more and more mindful communities around
the world
where we can come together we can sit we
can share our suffering we can share the
difficulties but then we can find a way
to take the next step
um there's a story that
that
motivates me every time i want to give
up um
and and
and this comes from um
during the vietnam war uh when tai and
his young social workers were going to
help rebuild bomb villages and there was
a particular village that kept getting
bombed
and by the third time that it was bombed
and tight and
told his um
his social worker we're gonna go again
and one of them said tai is it even
worth it if we know that tomorrow it
will be bombed again and that was a
voice of despair
and tai took a pause and i think it
really hit him too and he had to
dig deep inside
and he said that
yes we do because our action
will light up hope
it will tell the people that there are
those around that care for them
so every time that you do
fall into a moment of despair
and you want to give up you still know
that there are actions that you can
offer today it may be it may seem very
little but it may have a very big impact
down the road and what tai and his
social worker offer is that
there is light at the end of the tunnel
there is hope because our action is
showing that humanity will come together
to help
the suffering that is present that's
beautiful
um
sister true dedication brother fapu
thank you so much that is uh
exquisite wisdom
brought to you from the
delightful grounds of the plum village
monastery in southern france you're
staying up late to talk to us we really
appreciate that we want to let you go
um
and but before we do it's something we
do in every episode we want to take you
through some lightning round questions
we're gonna this is perhaps not in the
spirit of your buddhist practice but
we're gonna mix it up a little bit we're
gonna throw some profound and also
ridiculous questions your way and just
the first thing that comes into your
mind i guess we can just kind of
tag team we'll start with brother fapu
and then we'll just go back and forth
and toss these little
uh thought grenades at you
brother
um if you could colonize mars would you
no
you have to think about being the first
buddhist on mars
no i want to take care of earth i like
earth right now all right for now he
really thought about that he really
thought about that did you see it i did
think about that
sister true education um
what is one skill you wish you had
uh being able to sing beautifully
well you have a lovely voice you have a
beautiful talking voice i have a spoken
voice i don't have a
singing voice but then hey here this is
how it goes
if i would have been able to sing i
think i would have gone into theater and
performing arts
so i made peace with this a couple of
years into being a nun and i was like
it's okay that i can't sing because if i
was if i could sing i would never have
made it into the monastery and i'd
probably be an alcoholic by now
in performing arts that's right so i was
like
okay fine
exactly you'd be an alcoholic like me
like smoking cigarettes in los angeles
unemployed and bitter
and instead you're
uh
changing the world inspiring the world
um brother fapu
uh if you could have lunch with any
author past or present who would it be
and why
ooh
with the author
is the buddha
i would want to have search with the
buddha yeah sure and i would like to
just see
how he eats his meal and
if he was actually super mindful like my
teacher
that's a good one
um okay uh
sister true dedication name something a
lot of people like but that you can't
stand
okay shiitake mushrooms ah shiitake
mushrooms
you know it's just i mean i love
mushroom i love i guess i love mushrooms
that kind of
they don't that are not like a sort of
um
sea vegetable that's going to come up
and eat you from the inside i don't know
this is the same way
they're so strong about these mushrooms
i feel the same way we've asked these
questions
dozens and dozens of times obviously
never to monks and now i understand why
we don't ask these questions
to monks first of all monks apparently
have no conception of lightning round
you know you ask them a question they're
like let me meditate on that for about
four minutes
i know
four minutes of radio silence hold on
yeah
well your editor will make it as though
you answer right away
you know what is what is one thing i
guess shiitake mushrooms yeah
um brother
if you
if you were stranded on a desert island
what are three items that you would take
with you
okay
a teapot
oh oh good one
tea yeah dude you're gonna do that and
a water boiler
it's all about the tea it's all about
do you have a tea addiction brother we
all do we all do so
this is the one thing that we are
allowed to enjoy
so we get we've given up alcohol meat
a lot of
whirly entertainment but tea is our
go-to this is how we party this is how
monastic party come and have a cup of
tea with me
wow party in the monastery
and then last but not least and this is
a question for each of you and sister
why don't you start
what is your life's big question
am i enough how can i be enough
i relate
um wow
how how how do you go after that um
big question
the perfect response would be is sister
true dedication enough
[Laughter]
how do we move forward that is my
question
that i meditate on a lot
beautiful
sister and brother thank you so much for
your time
uh this has been a beautiful profound
and deeply moving conversation
i think you will have brought some peace
a little peace and enlightenment to
everyone that has listened to this and i
can't thank you enough
wow what a conversation uh that was so
moving i was so
uh and i am so awestruck by their work
and their spirit the power of that their
recharged mindfulness spiritual
batteries that power just comes through
like i felt all of a sudden like i was
really wound up this morning and i was
like seven minutes into that interview
and i just
ah my shoulders just went down by about
three or four inches and started
noticing my breath i was listening much
more keenly and carefully than i usually
do
um really transformative you know i and
i i'll be honest i was kind of nervous
about this podcast
uh because i don't know maybe it's
because i think that monks have like
um
mindfulness x-ray vision like they they
would be able to see through my body and
realize you know
see see what a shallow
yeah yeah what a shallow petty
unspiritual yeah well i i see you reza i
see you uh so but yeah they were just
wonderful and i loved you know exactly
kind of what we've always talked about
you know in in so many different ways
about living out your morality and
inner peace is the beginning of
of the striving for activism and
engagement
uh with the world but how important it
is to kind of start with yourself i mean
going back to the the social media
conversation we were having at the
beginning of this episode
yeah you did and and for those listeners
who who don't know
you did um in inspired by uh dr anna
lemke in her writings about dopamine you
did a dopamine fast which for you had a
lot to do with twitter because you would
endlessly poop and twitter and check
your twitter and retweet
angrily and reactively so you took a
month off from that you got a little
clarity and so now now what i took a
month off of it i i got a little bit of
clarity um
and then
and then i was like okay well you know
it's been a month let me go back in and
see and see where where i am
and i got online and you know wanted to
kind of start you know talking about
football
all these exciting trades happening the
draft is coming up and i was like okay i
want to kind of get that seems like a
safe way back into twitter
you know i'm not talking about war
or politics
and oh man let me tell you rain
i was on twitter for about
four minutes and i was like i hate
everyone
on this thing like it was
it was so weird to be back and just be
like this place sucks
these people suck
i i've been on it for four minutes i'm
already in a bad mood
and uh you know
i i so i just kind of got off again and
yeah i've gone on for a couple of
minutes here a couple of minutes there
you know but
i feel like i've i've really
i get this idea and i'm not saying that
i'm like ready to go join plum village
not yet
plus right just my hair is magnificent
like could you
could you imagine it's a very it's a
distinguished grey and a full head of
hair so full and full of light like it
would be like a crime against humanity
to cut this hair a crime against god
really folks maybe we inspired you to
become monks
you know um and if not monks might be
monks in your own life
to bring a practice of uh deep
mindfulness
which then leads to a mindfulness of
suffering your own and others and which
then leads
to action
because that's the whole
gd point of it all reza is not just to
feel a little bit better so that you can
try and make more money and continue
with your crazy hectic meaningless life
but actually
work at making the world a slightly
better place and then and here's the key
here's the key and then in that action
that's where enlightenment
comes
right it's not like you go inside to get
enlightened and then you go do things
it's like
that's the that's the process like
inside outside then enlightenment yeah i
view it as like a yin and yang like you
you charge your batteries and that's
that energy then you take that out you
give that to the world you're expending
your energy you run out you go in again
there's a cyclical process happening but
um we'd love to hear from you folks do
you have a cyclical mindfulness process
happening
one good way to reach us is to just hit
us up on our social medias you can find
those pretty easily
you can also follow on instagram uh at
metaphysical milkshake
and
uh at metamilkpodcast on twitter or
review us on apple podcasts give us a
positive review leave us your life's big
question we'll track you down i still
don't know how they do that somehow or
other they'll attempt to track you down
from that and bring you on the show
because we love to have fan guests on
the show interacting with us asking
their life's big pertinent question
thank you so much again to brother fapu
and sister true dedication
okay milkshakers as you know when you
rate and review us on apple podcasts and
you ask some big life question
you get to come on our show and ask that
question of us and who knows maybe even
get an answer that has something to do
with the topic that you are asking about
but very likely not
uh and today's guest is liz from
california hi liz how are you
hey you're doing well thank you so much
for having me where in california are
you calling from
i am here from sunny los angeles
hey that's where i live
maybe we'll run into each other some
point in life here in l.a i hope i hope
we will and until that time comes why
what brings you to the old milkshake bar
what do you got you got a question you
need to put in the blender
see what i did there rezab yeah you
really extended that metaphor until it
was finally just like begging for death
but uh go ahead liz
yes so this is a question that has been
i guess bragging my brain for a while
and
it has to do with the feeling of when
you have chemistry with someone
because
when we talk about chemistry or when i
ask people about chemistry
it always seems like this mysterious
unseen force that
i feel like only humans really
understand or that we actually feel
and we only really know that because
we've experienced this
whenever we have chemistry with someone
or we've also experienced when there is
a total absence
of chemistry
and
popularly we know romantic chemistry but
there's also chemistry between friends
and
podcast
podcast hosts exactly you two have a
specific kind of chemistry that comes
off when you talk with each other and
creative chemistry as well so
my question is what exactly is chemistry
to you and what do you think is the
purpose of it as human beings
i mean
you know for me it's funny because like
i don't think that this is really um
all that kind of mysterious you know
because there's so much science now
about the
the chemical reactions that are involved
you know when it comes to
um attraction right like the
testosterone and the estrogen levels
that suddenly spike when you see someone
that you're attracted to or like the
dopamine levels which we've been talking
about a lot you know um serotonin
rushes that you get when like somebody
you know when you touch someone in this
in a certain way but even you know i
think about
my relationship with my wife
um and
so much of it is chemical it's crazy you
know like the wait what
she is she's like my oxytocin
dosage you know like there's like i i
find myself in need of
touching her or smelling her you know
like it's it's like whatever the the
chemicals are inside me and whatever is
inside her from like the second we set
eyes on each other they
just pulled us towards each other
um
and
and i've also like had experiences where
i've been with seeing someone that i
like physically i'm attracted to like
this is an attractive person i you know
and they are
fun and funny and they have a great
personality
but i there's just something you know
like it's just like the way that their
skin smells or
there's just a like a a real
chemical
kind of opposite very this is very
getting very inappropriately sexual all
of a sudden i'm feeling
eventually gets down to i feel like i'm
getting to know and then
and then be like and then jessica and i
when we make love it's like i've talked
about our love making on this podcast a
few times now
we don't need to get too involved in it
all i'm saying is that like i am a
hundred percent like firm believer in
the science of attraction you know that
i really do think it's it's like at a
deep chemical bond
level and by the way i would say i i
feel like that that's true
even like non-sexually a little bit you
know we did we had we did this uh
podcast episode one of my favorites uh
where we talked to um
uh
uncle rhett
reigns reigns uncle yes
about beauty attraction and like beauty
and what like beauty actually does to
you and i made a confession
uh and rain made fun of me i made a
confession that like if i were to be
perfectly honest with you
all of
my friends the friends that i that i'm
closest to
i'm also
attracted to
and
friends that i've had for a long time
that you would think we would get closer
and closer i think part of the reason
why i'm not closer and closer is because
i'm not
physically attracted to them and it
keeps me from getting any closer
i think that applies to this i i really
think that it's like this chemical thing
that's happening
that's i'm reza's one unattractive
friend that he allows you in his life
by the way i just don't like rub my body
all over you i want to like i want to
take i want to dive head first into your
belly button sometimes yeah you know liz
i i don't i don't know much about it
this is a great question i haven't
thought much about it but what comes to
mind for me is i agree with reza that
it's it may be not any kind of mystical
thing it's just two energies coming
together
and
i feel like when you have a great
chemistry between two people
um
then it kind of creates a a third person
like there's person one person two and
then there's the entity number three
like when those two people are together
that's larger than the sum of its parts
and
that's um
that's pretty cool i think and there is
a spiritual dimension to that in that
this larger than the sum of its parts
energy can perhaps help make the world a
better place and can be harnessed and
utilized in some way and there isn't
just that chemistry there can also be a
chemistry of when a when a group of
people come together and then a
community of people come together and
then a a tribe and a state a village in
a state and a and a nation of people
coming together and maybe that's the
kind of chemistry we're all trying to
build down here on planet earth maybe
we've focused too much in the western
world on sexual and romantic chemistry
reza and not focused so much on
kind of
uh proactive spiritual chemistry what do
you think liz
well
i've spoken to a couple of my friends
about this question just to see what
they
what they answer what they
describe when it comes to chemistry
and just taking all that in i'm still
trying to figure that out myself but
the best way that i can explain it is
i feel like as humans we have some sort
of energy whether if it's like aura or
you know we're we're projecting some
kind of energy out into the world
and when we do that and when we do have
an interaction with someone i feel like
we're vibrating at some frequency let's
say like the frequency is here right but
then when
we interact with someone and then their
frequency just happens to be that same
frequency that's kind of like the
matching where it becomes kind of like a
synergistic kind of
interaction with someone where it feels
easy because whenever people talk about
having chemistry it's not forced and
there's some sort of ease or you kind of
feel like you've known this person for a
while but you really haven't but just
something clicks with you
um
so that's kind of what i think about
chemistry but then
i also think about chemistry as like
let's say two people are reactants
and they just they create a product
whatever that product is but then
chemistry is kind of like the catalyst
that kind of makes it go faster or kind
of has like kind of like that explosive
kind of effect in a reaction where
chemistry when you feel it
it it hits you you know exactly that it
is chemistry
um so that's kind of
my idea of what chemistry is it's not
very you know scientific even though i
am kind of speaking on scientific terms
in that way but i feel like it's a lot
to do with energy and kind of
a matching that happens with people
um
but then i also wonder if chemistry is
something that is instant like is it
something that you either have or you
don't with someone upon first meeting or
do you think that it can
be developed over time and if it's
developed over time is that really
chemistry or is it now something else
yeah yeah that's a good those are good
questions
like i don't know i mean i
i feel like you know if it's chemistry
it's like an instant thing but i suppose
you could eventually you know
it's it's the same way that they talk
about how like dog owners and their dogs
start to look alike after a while
um
i can see that kind of working but
i don't know maybe it's not nearly as
romantic as the instant instant chemical
reaction
what do you think rain
i i feel a little out of my depth to be
perfectly honest i think you've kind of
stumped us
well
stopped you but okay
you've stumped
me thank you so much
thank you for listening everybody on
behalf of the las vegas raiders and
everyone here at
media and metaphysical milkshake and the
las vegas
raiders thank you so much for tuning in
metaphysical milkshake is executive
produced by rayne wilson reza aslan and
colin thompson it is produced by safa
samazadeh yazd harris lane mick demaria
hashem self and dj lubel
cast media is the production and
distribution partner original music by
jeff tang
what do you think ryan are you ready are
you ready to get your gray rope well i'm
not reza because here's the problem look
at my head i mean it's enormous i think
you'd look great
sister true dedication you have no idea
what this watermelon would look like
yeah i would get i would get run out of
plum village
you'd look fabulous you'd breathe
mindfully you'd walk mindfully it would
all look great it would it would be
wonderful
hey thanks for watching you guys for
more fantastic videos just like the one
that you watch please subscribe to our
youtube channel thank you